ses apparitions se font de plus en plus
rares mais simone veil ancien ministre
de la santé celle qui a défendu et
obtenu le droit à l'avortement a tenu à
être présente pour l'inauguration de
l'ufr des sciences de la santé de
montigny qui porte dorénavant son nom
une ufr des sciences de la santé
autrement dit une université où l'on
enseigne à la fois le médical et le
paramédical première particularité la
seconde cette ufr est implantée dans la
ville et non au sein d'un établissement
hospitalier universitaire comme cela se
voit couramment et ce n'est pas un
hasard
on pense que ça ça permet pour partie de
réseaux des deux traités
les difficultés que l'on a à former des
professions de santé on pense peut-être
faire soit des maisons de santé
universitaire soit des pôles de santé
qui vont aider des endroits de soins de
premier recours et qui permettrait
peut-être de désengorger un petit peu
les urgences des hôpitaux auraient puis
de prendre en charge de façon
très universitaire je dirais des malades
si ie tous les étudiants sont formés en
centre ville si tous les étudiants
passent l'ensemble de leur cursus
universitaire à l'intérieur de l'hôpital
il y a peu de chances pour qu'ils aient
envie d'aller s'installer à l'extérieur
de l'hôpital et encore moins à
l'extérieur des grandes villes donc
c'est évidemment un enjeu tout à fait
important rapprocher la formation des
lieux d'installation à venir
la lutte contre les déserts médicaux la
ministre présentera prochainement des
mesures dans ce sens autre application
de l'ufr des sciences de la santé qui a
convaincu marisol touraine la
mutualisation des moyens entre
différentes disciplines
dans ce laboratoire par exemple les
chercheurs traite des pathologies liées
à des traumatismes de la moelle osseuse
de la recherche fondamentale avec des
buts appliquer au quotidien
quand là
la personne a eu un accident de voiture
ou a subi une atteinte au niveau du
système nerveux central ça a des
conséquences sur sa sexualité et sa
comptine ans donc on travaille sur des
modèles animaux de façon à comprendre et
à pallier éventuellement dans l'avenir
c'est trouble particulier en trouvant
des médicaments qui pourraient agir sur
la relaxation delà de la vessie d'une
part ou en interrogeant plus précisément
le système nerveux central de façon à
faire des thérapies novatrices et en
particulier thérapie à base de
transferts de jeunes
l'ufr des sciences de la santé avait été
pensé dès 2003 il est situé à deux pas
du centre commercial régional accueille
mille étudiants en première année et
5000 en totalité les amphis sont plus
adaptées c'est exclusivement des cours
de médecine je pense contrairement à
l'ancienne fac après moi je trouve un
peu moins chaleureuse c'est plus austère
ben est très sympa
elle est plus proche de la gare donc
c'est plus rapide donc ces pratiques en
tout cette ufr compte 125 enseignants et
18 laboratoires mixtes